and I had an old agent telling me you're
not a covergirl you are only gonna be my
money catalog girl and you're just gonna
be under the radar I think that just
speaking your mind and making yourself
different than everybody else is really
what's going to get you on the map
you're as good as your last job and so
every job I treat it as if it were my
last job need motivation watch a top 10
of the leave nation what's up at seven
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out onto the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a woman who went
from growing up with ADHD and dyslexia
to becoming a successful model and
entrepreneur she's Ashley Graham and
here's my take on her top ten rules to
success enjoy
all right let's take things off with
rule number one my personal favorite
take control there was a moment in my
career actually right before I started
my lingerie line and I had an old agent
telling me you're not a covergirl you
are only gonna be my money catalog girl
and you're just gonna be under the radar
I waited on him to build a career for me
and I waited on him to kind of guide me
into success and the moment that I let
him just kind of step to the sidelines
and I took control over my own career is
the moment that I started a sky rocket
and I could have had it earlier I really
believe rule number two
is fake it till you make it I wake up
some days and I feel like I'm going to
take over the world and conquer
everything in life and then the next day
I feel like the most insecure person in
the world and I really think those low
days are the days that you have to give
yourself affirmations that you have to
talk yourself out of that funk that you
have to make sure that you're
surrounding yourself with people who
aren't gonna take you down I mean like I
had a boyfriend who you know was a
negative person in my life and did I
realize it early enough no it took me
two years to understand that and it was
a perpetual negativity and I think that
if you have the tools to make that bad
day a good day you fake it till you make
it you use those affirmations you two
can have a good day but it's really just
about making a conscious effort yeah
absolutely fake it till you make it I'm
that's how I got here yeah rule number
three ignore the haters
[Music]
usually like if I have a little bit of
cellulite hanging out people freak out
stop making fat cool you're gonna kill
somebody you cannot be a model oh my god
you're not Adriana Lima obviously it's
called go to the gym at the end of the
day you know what happens I read these
comments and I just kind of like brushed
it off my shoulder women of all shapes
and sizes ages and ethnicities are
beautiful rule number four is be
authentic authenticity is key in my
brand and I feel like part of my success
has been me just being me and I really
want women to understand and men to
understand if you were just you and you
don't conform to what everybody else is
doing in the beauty world and the
business world whatever it may be that's
really what's gonna make you successful
I think that just speaking your mind and
making yourself different than everybody
else is really what's going to get you
on the map I was in a commercial that
was banned from television and I took
that and turned it into something that
could really be eye-opening for women
and I started a platform the lingerie
line and I started talking to women
about being comfortable in their own
skin and then it led to the TED talk and
then it led to a cover Sports
Illustrated
rule number five is be a boss there's a
part of your book where you're talking
about your lingerie show yes and about
the hair and makeup and about there was
something with a makeup that you didn't
weren't really right with and you told
them but you told them with your laughs
and in a way that made it feel like you
were just being very nice about it right
yes I'm 29 years old and I've had to
really make a lot of hard decisions up
until this point a lot of big business
decisions as well and in that moment I
was like how do I tell them I don't like
this makeup but not tell them in a way
that's going to take away all the
creative that they even thought to put
together and I just basically said it
and I was like I don't want to sound
like a [ __ ] because you always are a
[ __ ] if you say it the wrong way
like get rid of squash that right is it
not a [ __ ] if you know whole thing the
way you want it exactly so I just did it
and they were like cool let's do it
because I don't think you will never
know the answer unless if you ask
and that's what my father always taught
me he's like you're never gonna know if
you don't ask so ask and that's what I
do and that's kind of how I also am
community I communicate with my team we
know we're a team but also we know that
we can talk very directly to each other
because that's how we set it up from the
beginning and whoever the boss is you
set the tone you know this is your arena
so how are you set the tone is the way
things are gonna go so I always set the
tone with kindness first and then let's
get ish done baby rule number six don't
let others define what is possible I
believe beauty is beyond size with so
much emphasis on the body and external
it's no wonder that we all suffer so
much internally but you know people in
the fashion industry actually told me
that I would never be in magazines let
alone the covers of them well I guess we
proven them wrong five covers and a
little over a year and I was one of the
very first curvy models to be featured
in Sports Illustrated Swimsuit Edition
thank you never let anybody tell you
that you can't I have achieved and I'm
still achieving what was seemingly
impossible rule number seven learned to
deal with criticism how did you learn to
not take rejection personally I have
taken a lot of criticism seriously and
it really eats at you and the moment you
say you know what I'm gonna take
everything with a grain of salt and
whatever somebody says to me maybe I'll
take it in I'll chew on it a little bit
and then we'll see really like is this
person coming from a good place or is
this person coming from a jealous or
negative place I like constructive
criticism I'm always asking my team or
it I feel like it makes you a better
model or you're a better employee a
better boss so I think it's important to
take in constructive criticism but at
the end of the day you are the one who's
supposed to know who you are and not let
anybody tell you who you are
rule number eight stop comparing
yourself to others
compare myself to other women desiring
their but their hair their skin color
their shape of their eyes the their
boyfriends I think that the moment that
I stopped comparing myself to other
women is the moment that I actually
became really successful and happy with
all of myself the laws and all honey
rule number nine treat every job as your
last I wanted to know what was the best
piece of advice that was given to you
when you started your modeling career I
best piece of advice that I was given
when I started my modeling career was
make sure that you under there was a lot
of things that weren't given to me
because you know everybody likes to give
you advice one thing that stayed with me
is you're as good as your last job and
so every job I treated as if it were my
last job and I think that that kind of
gave me a reputation of hard-working
ready to do whatever it takes to get
this shot and and I and I think that
that's very important in any industry
and rule number ten the last one before
the bonus Clips love yourself as a young
model my confidence was tugged at and
pulled in all different directions I
struggled to achieve true confidence I
would go home and look in front of the
mirror and only hate what I saw and to
fill the void on the inside I began to
came to all the vices being thrown my
way between the parties the men alcohol
I was looking for self-love for
affirmation from somebody when in
reality I didn't love who I was and I
couldn't seem to get a handle on
regulating my own weight I began to
thought to I began to face my
insecurities head-on and instead I was
filling my life with temporary fixes I
like so many young women have struggled
to love Who I am
and doves global report on attitudes
towards beauty actually did a survey
to wit thousands of women in ten
different countries and you know what
the most striking result was that only
2% of women find themselves beautiful 2%
we need to work together to redefine the
global vision of beauty and it starts
with becoming your own role model be you
be real be authentic be your favorite
kind of woman don't let anybody else
take that job and remember this is the
generation of body diversity
now I've got a special Ashley Graham
bonus clip but before that my question
of the day for you guys is around her
rule number two fake it to you make it
what do you think about that are you
faking it to you make it do you buy into
that strategy or not I'd love to hear
your thoughts leave it down in the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clip
and something i did when i was announced
as one of the rookies for some Sports
Illustrated is I started reading the
comments after they had announced me and
I literally started hysterically crying
because there were men who were like who
is this fat cow who now is in in Sports
Illustrated how dare she come in there
was women that were saying oh I work out
every single day of my life and then
this heifer can come in and be in a
magazine and reading that at first
really just made me feel like I've
ruined the magazine they took a chance
on a big girl now I ruined it for them
and then I don't know why but I kept
reading because you get into a black
hole it's like it's like a car crash
series like wait a minute like a black
hole you can just be like next page next
page
who knew comments oh it's crazy and then
all of a sudden people started standing
up for me and saying no this is what we
need this is where the industry should
be going and I really think that from
that moment I'm like nah I can't just be
like about the haters I can't like feed
into what they're saying about me I have
to know that there's so many other men
and women out there who need
representation like this who need
representation on a whole other scale
that we still don't see in social media
in in fashion so it made me really
excited after that when I was like you
know what let the haters be the haters
and let them be your motivators and you
know I'm so excited when I get to talk
to my fans on social media I will always
go in and kind of like read the comments
and say what's up or you know if they
have a question about like what sizing
my bras are but make sure you you know
size down or size up you know all of
that stuff so it's fun it's actually I
like to engage with them when you're
changing an industry you're going to
hear negative stuff constantly
and I have and I've been told no and
I've been told you can't you won't you
will never but here I am and you did
boom raise your standard Apple at the
core is core value
is that we believe that people have
passion and change the way people not
one drop of myself work depends on your
acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details